لقد تم للتو وضع السيد حكيمي
القاضي يفحص تهمة الاغتصاب
من التعليمات للأسف
تنتهي الملفات التي تم نشرها بشكل طفيف
دائما عن طريق التسرب بطريقة واحدة أو
ومن ناحية أخرى، كلما تضاعفنا
المستجيبين وزيادة خطر التسرب
في ملف مهم وبين
مرحلة تقديم الشكوى أو
في أي حال من الأحوال في اللحظة التي يكون فيها المشتكي
يدفع باب مركز الشرطة
حتى لحظة قاضي التحقيق
سوف يستقبل السيد الحكيمي على ما تعتقد
على الرغم من الناس الذين يتعاملون معها
هذا الملف عديدة وأن
وتتزايد مخاطر التسربات
من الواضح في الوقت الراهن يا سيدي
ومن الواضح أن الحكيمي بريء
مما يعني أنه تم وضعها
الفحص يعني أن التحقيق هو
يستمر وتم وضعه من قبل القاضي
التحقيق تحت إشراف قضائي
الرقابة القضائية تعني أننا
يفرض عليه عددا معينا
من الالتزامات و/أو الحظر في
الواقعة الممنوع من دخولها
فيما يتعلق بهذه المرأة الشابة ولكن
ولا يمنع من ممارسته
المهنة ولا الخروج عن حدود
الأراضي الوطنية مما يعني
أنه يستطيع الاستمرار في ذلك بشكل مثالي
العب ومواصلة اللعب
الدولية ولذلك لا ينبغي أن يكون
يأتي ويعيق مسيرته في أي حال
لاعب دولي ل
في هذه اللحظة لا أصدق لا أصدق
لا أن الالتزام بالبقاء في
لقد فرضت عليه فرنسا وأعتقد ذلك
في إطار المراجعة القضائية
سمح له القاضي بالاستمرار
السفر هو الحظر
أننا نأتي لنسأل عندما نخشى ذلك
الناس يهربون في الواقع
بخصوص السيد حكيمي نعرف
الذي يحتاج إلى السفر من أجله
تتطلب نشاطه
المهنية بداهة نحن لا نأخذ
خطر كبير في السماح له بالسفر
مع باريس سان جيرمان لا أعتقد أنه كذلك
أما بالنسبة لفكرة الهروب فهي ليست كذلك على الإطلاق
في هذه الحالة الذهنية أعتقد ذلك
وأشار محاميه أيضًا إلى أنه
كان أكثر من راغب في الشرح
بسبب اتهاماته أمام المحاكم
الفرنسية لذلك لا أعتقد أن أي شخص
لا يمكن أن يخشى بشكل معقول أنه
وبالتالي يختفي هذا الحظر على
مغادرة فرنسا لم تحدث
ليكون الشخص الذي يسعى
هو المدعي العام
تقديم شكوى يسمح بذلك ببساطة
أن يكون المدعي العام
أبلغ أنه في مكان ما في فرنسا في أ
في اللحظة التي حدث فيها شيء ما
ولكن تقديم شكوى بطريقة
الرسمي ليس إلزاميا لذلك
أن المدعي العام بطريقة أو بأخرى
يتم إبلاغ آخر بوجود جريمة
يمكن أن تكون حرة في المشاركة
الملاحقات القضائية وهناك منذ ذلك الحين
دخلت شابة أ
مركز الشرطة ليأتي ويشرح
الأثر الذي استنكرته ولو أنها
لم أرغب في تقديم شكوى
كان كافيا للنيابة العامة
الحصول على المعلومات وتكون قادرة على
اتخاذ قرار بشأن الملاحقات القضائية لدينا نفس الشيء
في بعض الأحيان الملفات التي
أصحاب الشكوى يقدمون شكاوى وينسحبون
شكاواهم هي نفسها، لم يفعلوا ذلك
لا شيء يتغير حتى الضحية الذي
سيأتي ويسحب شكواه
ولا يمنع المدعي من
الجمهورية لتحقيق الأجل هو
الملاحقة القضائية ثم قد يكون هناك
أسباب متعددة يمكن أن يكون بسبب
لقد كذبنا هذا هذا
الاحتمال الأول يمكن أن يكون أيضا
لأنك تعرف رحلة أ
الضحية في المحكمة هي رحلة
ثقيل جدًا وهذا أخيرًا بين
اللحظة التي ندين فيها الحقائق و
اللحظة التي ندرك فيها أننا سنضطر إلى ذلك
مواجهة الجبل
التحقيق لإجراء الفحوصات الطبية
الامتحانات النفسية القادمة
مقابلة قاضي التحقيق
ربما تواجهه
المعتدي يمكن أن يكون هناك أيضا
الضحايا الذين يختارون ذلك في النهاية
استسلم لأنه أ
بالطبع عقبة وأنه من الضروري
كن قويا جدا لمواجهة هذا
لذلك يمكن أيضًا أن نكون قادرين أيضًا
أفهم أن امرأة شابة ثم أنا
لا أعرف على الإطلاق إذا كان هذا هو الحال.
في هذا الملف ولكن امرأة شابة
يأتي لدفع باب مركز الشرطة
للتنديد بحفلات الاغتصاب التي لم تفعلها
بالضرورة تريد على الفور أن تذهب
الاستلقاء على طاولة الفحص
الطبيب للقيام
التحقيقات الطبية هو الفعل
وهو عنيف للغاية للغاية
تدخلي ويمكن أن يكون للغاية
مؤلمة للضحية التي تأتي
يدين بالفعل أعمال الاغتصاب لذلك فهو
هناك مجموعة كاملة من الأسباب التي يمكن أن تفعل ذلك
تعال واشرح لماذا الضحية
إما أن يسحب شكواه أو لا يرغب
عدم الخضوع للتحقيقات التي
والذي من الواضح أنه سيكون مرغوبًا من قبل
المحققين والقاضي
المدرب العدالة الفرنسية
في الواقع طويلة للأسف
لأنها تفتقر إلى الوسائل
ببساطة لو كان لدينا ضعف
لقاضي التحقيق ضعف
كاتب في محاكمنا بشكل واضح
سيتم تقليل عبء العمل و
يمكن أن تسير بشكل أسرع
في تحقيقاتهم بعد ذلك لدينا جميعا
طريقة عدد معين من التحقيقات
والتي تستغرق وقتا أي.
تشغيل الهاتف
سماع شهود التحقيق
الطبية أو الخبرة
هم النفسية على أي حال
العناصر التي تستغرق وقتا و
وهو أيضًا وقت ضروري
لظهور الحق ولكن
ما قانون الإجراءات الجنائية
يوفر ذلك في ملف
المجرمين قاضي التحقيق في سن 18
أشهر لاستكمال ذلك ثم هو عليه
موعد نهائي إرشادي ولكن مع ذلك
يسمح لك بإراحة المؤشر قليلاً
كنت سأقول الصعوبة هناك بالنسبة ل
بالنسبة للتوقيت فهو السيد أكيمي
تركت حرة تحت السيطرة
القضائية وذلك بسبب
عبء العمل على قضاتنا
للتعليمات التي تحدثت معك عنها
لحظة للأسف أو
لحسن الحظ ولكن الأولوية تعطى
في الملف الذي الناس
المعتقلين ليس هذا هو حال السيد.
حكيمي التحقيق سيأخذ مجراه
ولكن من الواضح أنه ربما مع القليل
سرعة أقل مما لو كانت
سجن ثم وضع تحت
كان من الممكن أن تكون المراقبة الإلكترونية
خيار ينظر فيه القاضي
من التعليمات وهذا يعني أن الوقت
من المعلومات القضائية هناك
عدة احتمالات إما الشخص
يتم وضعها في الحجز أو هي
يوضع تحت المراقبة القضائية أو
لقد تركت حرة تمامًا أيضًا
تم وضعها تحت المراقبة
الكتروني مع تركيب سوار
وهذا يسمح بمزيد من التحكم في
شخص من مقياس بسيط لل
المراجعة القضائية لم تكن هناك
اختيار قاضي التحقيق الذي
اختار وضع السيد الحكيمي تحت
الرقابة القضائية دون هذا الإجراء
سوار الذي يبدو نسبيا
منطقي لأننا نعلم أنه سيكون
اللازمة للسفر والاحتياجات
يجري بعيدا عن المنزل تركيب أ
سوار إنه شيء جدا
ملزم، وهذا يعني أنك
ملزمة بالجداول الزمنية لديك
سوار الكاحل المتصل به
سكن
الهاتف إلى منفذ الطاقة الخاص بك
سوار قطع ذلك لك
تسمح لك بالذهاب إلى العمل على سبيل المثال
من الساعة 9 صباحًا حتى الساعة 6 مساءً ولكن لا يمكننا أن نتخيل ذلك
افصل السوار ل
وقت الأسبوع للذهاب للعب مباراة
لا أعرف أين ثم نعيد الاتصال
السوار بعد ذلك ونحن
إعادة الاتصال في اليوم التالي ل
التدريب وما إلى ذلك
سوار انها حقا انها تقريبا
مثل الإقامة الجبرية هناك
واعتبر قاضي التحقيق أن هذا
لم يكن من الضروري للسيد.
للسيد الحكيمي وذلك موضع
تحت المراقبة القضائية كان كافيا
بإسهاب